und jetzt das heute journal
bettina zimmermann und christian sievers
hallo und guten abend hinein wenn zwei
verlieren und einer gewinnt aber alle
drei ein team bilden sollen dann können
wir uns alle vorstellen das wird nicht
leicht und man muss nicht beziehungs
therapeut sein um festzustellen dass
wird einiges verschieben im internen
gefüge die grünen halten sich heute an
psychologisch wertvollen rat und
verzichten auf allzu großes gewinner
getöse obwohl sie die großen gewinner
sind in nordrhein-westfalen historisch
gut abgeschnitten haben und das auch für
ihre bundespolitik als bestätigung sehen
spd und fdp müssen sich dagegen fragen
lassen was schief gelaufen ist und vor
allem was sie jetzt tun um das ruder
rumzureißen
die ampel nach der wahl die mehr war als
eine entscheidung für nrw britta
buchholz
es ist eine herbe niederlage für die spd
und für die ampel scholz war zwar im
wahlkampf stark engagiert doch
rückenwind für die wahlkämpfer in
nordrhein westfalen war das wohl nicht
heute lässt der kanzler den parteichef
reden und der sieht ausgerechnet als
fehler nummer eins mangelnder
kommunikation
wir haben zugelassen dass zu viel über
waffenlieferungen und zu wenig über
gestiegene lebenshaltungskosten und zu
wenig über gestiegene energiepreise auch
in der kommunikation geredet wurde und
das ist eine der rückschlüsse die man
auch aus dem ergebnis gestern bei der
landtagswahl ziehen kann zudem seien
gerade themen wie die energiepreise
nicht genug erklärt worden eine herbe
niederlage ist es vor allem auch für den
anderen ampel partner die fdp die partei
hat gerade ältere wähler dramatisch
verloren lindner sieht als einen grund
dafür die energiepreis pauschale sie
entlastet arbeitnehmer rentner aber
nicht die idee dazu hätten aber andere
gehabt es ist der bundesregierung nicht
gelungen die frage der gerechtigkeit der
energiepreis pauschale befriedigend zu
beantworten die energiepreis pauschale
war wie sie wissen keine initiative der
freien demokraten sondern kam aus dem
kreis der koalitionspartnerinnen und
koalitionspartner manch einer fürchtet
gar ein muster sobald die liberalen
regieren verlieren sie bei den wahlen
die grünen dagegen gewinnen schlechte
aussichten für die harmonie der berliner
ampel wir haben gegenwärtig keine zeit
und keinen raum uns vertieften und
selbst zu beschäftigen so lange es krise
und krieg gibt solange wichtige vorhaben
dieses land stabil und erfolgreich zu
halten umgesetzt werden müssen ich mache
mir um das nervenkostüm anderer
überhaupt keine sorgen alle die ich
erlebe in dieser koalition wissen wie
groß die aufgaben sind sind gefasst sehr
professionell nur etwas könnte riskant
seien grüne minister viborg und habe
weglaufen anderen den rang ab und
während die drei ampel partner das
ergebnis klein reden reden es andere
groß friedrich merz sieht seine cdu
wieder zurück auf platz eins unter den
deutschen parteien die rolle des
kanzlers bewährten regierung und
opposition sehr unterschiedlich das
ergebnis ist das schlechteste
wahlergebnis dass die spd nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg in nordrhein westfalen
erzielt hat das wahlergebnis ist eine
ganz klare antwort auch an die
bundesregierung und insbesondere an den
bundeskanzler er hat große wahlen mit
der art wie er kommuniziert gewonnen und
dementsprechend ist es überhaupt kein
thema in der koalition die politik des
bundeskanzlers wird dort von der
mehrheit der bürgerinnen und bürger
unterstützt und deswegen gibt es da kein
bedarf etwas zu ändern
die ampel ist ein experiment von dem spd
fdp und grüne recht unterschiedlich
profitieren dazu eine gestärkte union
für die arbeit der koalition dürfte es
noch schwieriger werden
johannes vogel stammt aus nordrhein
westfalen und ist stellvertretender fdp
chef und jetzt bei uns genannt der vogel
stunden haben der sie was müssen sich
ihre koalitionspartner in berlin jetzt
warm anziehen also ich glaube wir haben
generell ja eine koalition in berlin wo
ganz unterschiedliche parteien
zusammenkommen mit unterschiedlichen
ideen und positionen und das soll auch
so bleiben wir wollen ja nicht heiraten
oder fusionieren aber wir wollen gut
zusammenarbeiten und das land gemeinsam
voranbringen und das ist nötig und daran
soll sich auch gar nichts ändern im
gegenteil jetzt hatte ihr parteichef
christian lindner heute gesagt als
ursache ausgemacht für das schlechte
abschneiden bei der nrw-wahl
unzufriedenheit mit dem gesamtpaket der
geplanten entlastungen was heißt denn
das für die regierungsarbeit jetzt ganz
konkret in der zukunft ja er hat ja
mehrere punkte genannt es gab ganz
sicher auch landespolitische
herausforderungen hier bei uns in
nordrhein westfalen in der pandemie für
die schulpolitik verantwortung zu tragen
ist extrem schwierig das ging den grünen
übrigens bei der landtagswahl vorher
ganz genau so und koalitionspartner hat
sicherlich auch wie soll ich sagen
versucht gemeinsam erfolge und stück
weit zu reklamieren und wir haben die
prägung der freien demokraten daran
vielleicht nicht über die jahre
ausreichend herausgearbeitet bekommen
aus all dem werden wir unsere lehren
ziehen hier in nordrhein westfalen aber
im bund geht es uns natürlich darum
gemeinsam weiter gut zu regieren das ist
klar und fordert eine entlastung das
haben sie folgen ja schon gesagt dass
sie gemeinsam gut regieren wollen die
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer möchten
sich nur vorstellen was das konkret
eigentlich bedeutet und was da auf sie
zukommt was wird sich denn jetzt konkret
ändern von fdp sollte ja ich habe ja
schon gesagt mit welcher einstellung wir
in diese koalition gehen und wenn ich
auf das land schauer dann stehen wir vor
ganz akuten herausforderungen durch den
krieg in der ukraine durch die inflation
die belastung der menschen und wir haben
ein riesen entlastungs paket geschnürt
wir werden natürlich uns offen halten
weiter zu reagieren wenn zb durch das öl
embargo was die eu prüft gegenüber
russland sich da weiteres entwickelt ich
finde aber wir müssen vor allem mutig
bleiben bei den modernisierungsprojekten
wenn wir eins doch auch lernen dieser
tage ist das wenn man herausforderungen
nicht rechtzeitig angeht dann holst 1 1
bei der bundeswehr bei der
energieabhängigkeit von russland und so
darf zum beispiel nicht sein bei der
demografie hohe stabilität in der rente
für eine generation brauchen oder bei
anderen themen wie der digitalisierung
sie waren als generalsekretär der fdp in
nordrhein westfalen beim letzten
wahlkampf federführend haben den
geleitet 2017 jetzt hat ihre partei
nicht mal mehr die hälfte des letzten
wahlergebnis in nrw geholt ist abgewählt
worden aus der regierung was anders
gelaufen ist als beim letzten mal ist
zumindest erst mal dass die fdp bislang
an der regierung war in düsseldorf und
in berlin
es gibt ja dieses mantra von christian
lindner besser nicht zu regieren als
falsch zu regieren jetzt regieren sie
und nach meinung der wähler offenbar
falsch was machen denn wer bock und
habeck besser als lindner und wissing ja
ich habe ja gerade schon gesagt wenn man
so eine wirklich schmerzhafte niederlage
1 führt dann muss man natürlich sich
alles anschauen weil er nie ein faktor
allein eine rolle spielt aber was machen
denn wer bock und harbeck anders und
besser als sind wissen wir haben ja zum
beispiel auch eine diskrepanz zwischen
dem bundes umfragen und jetzt im
ergebnis in nrw und deshalb muss man
schon auf die herausforderung nrw auch
schauen wenn man auf die in die ursachen
gucken will ich habe eben zwei ja auch
ganz konkret ganz offen genannt den
grünen ging es zb genauso bei der
letzten landtagswahl 2017 da kamen die
aus der regierung zweistellig gegen ja
auf rund 6 personen ist jetzt ganz haben
sie ja gerade schon genannt raus nach
vorne kommen lassen sie uns doch einfach
nach vorne gucken und da sehen wir dass
die grünen sehr viel draus machen können
aus dem was ihr im bund gerade machen
auch bei den landtagswahlen deswegen ich
stelle die frage noch mal was machen
berbalk und harbeck besser als lindner
und wissen ich will der frage gar nicht
ausreichen dass sie was ich wollte nur
auf die auf die unterschiedlichen
ursachen seiner wahlniederlage gucken
ich glaube was wir eindeutig erleben auf
bundesebene ist ja das natürlich extreme
aufmerksamkeit gerade im bereich des
außenministeriums im bereich des energie
und wirtschaftsministeriums liegen und
das muss ja auch so sein weil wir da
gerade in einer akuten krise sind und
ich will das ehrlich gesagt nicht anders
weil das die regierung ist die wir ja
auch genauso habe ich auch mal in der
fdp debatte erlebt in als wir mal das
außenministerium in der bundesregierung
hatten und dann war der mediale fokus
jahrelang woanders das ist das ein
fehler sei das außenministerium zu
beantragen zu westerwelles zeiten jetzt
wahr ist das finanzministerium war das
absolute wunsch ministerium von
christian lindner gewesen ist das
eigentlich der kardinalfehler schon von
anfang an nie das care schluss daraus
kann doch nur sein er sie weiß dass
unsere welt so komplex und ist uns so
dynamisch dass man nicht nach pr
aspekten ministerien raussuchen sollte
sondern nach seinen überzeugungen die
themen die man glaubt an packen zu
müssen und eines kann ich ihnen sagen
die grundlagen für künftige
wirtschaftlichen künftigen
wirtschaftlichen erfolg solide finanzen
gute rahmenbedingungen für unternehmer
bildung innovation an denen zu arbeiten
das ist so nötig das wird sich
langfristig auszahlen haben nicht fest
von überzeugt und mediale fokus das
ändert sich ganz dynamisch damit muss
man immer umgehen der politik jetzt legt
der mediale fokus natürlich auch auf dem
finanzminister und dem finanzministerium
bei dem er ausgerechnet als liberaler
allerdings aktuell einen rekord
schuldenberg verantworten muss also
etwas was der kernklientel ihrer partei
doch zutiefst zuwider ist ja ich weiß
nicht wie es ihnen geht mein eindruck
ist dass wir zum beispiel sehen dass die
bundeswehr kaputtgespart wurde und
dieses land viel zu lange darüber hinweg
gesehen hat das meine ich mit die großen
herausforderungen ich rechtzeitig
angehen und das jetzt mit einmalig 100
milliarden auszugleichen das ist doch
offensichtlich nötig für unsere äußere
sicherheit und dafür ist dann auch
richtig sie mit einem sondervermögen zu
verschulden der staat muss ja in solchen
krisenzeiten handlungsfähig seien nur
die voraussetzung dafür ist dass wir
auch künftig wirtschaftlich erfolgreich
sind und dass wir in guten zeiten auch
solide finanzen achten und darauf wird
auf die freien demokraten ankommen
obwohl ganz interessant was der nrw ihr
nrw spitzenkandidat herrscht am heute
morgen sagt die frage nach der ampel
sagte er die stellt sich nicht jetzt
wird es schwarz grün ist das eine weise
voraussage auch für den bund nein das
ist eine voraussage hierfür
nordrhein-westfalen wir haben zwei
wahlsieger das muss man in einer
demokratie auch mit respekt anerkennen
und gleichzeitig wissen wir dass die cdu
ja nicht immer mit besonderer inhalts
getriebenheit hervor sticht das heißt
sowie die bei uns projekte gerne
übernommen talent schulen für
chancengerechtigkeit wirtschaftliche
entfesselung werden die das auch bei den
grünen tun und sich sehr wahrscheinlich
einigen und das ist ihr gutes recht sie
haben den regierungsbildungsauftrag und
im bund wollen wir dafür sorgen dass das
liegenlassen der letzten jahre bei den
großen herausforderungen jetzt in dieser
konstellation geändert wird das kann
doch nur der schluss daraus seien sich
mutig in die aufgaben zu stürzen und die
modernisierungsprojekte anzugehen die
wir uns vorgenommen haben das doch
offensichtlich was unser land braucht
sagt johannes vogel der stellvertretende
fdp-chef vielen dank für das gespräch
sehr gerne
und das gespräch haben wir aus
termingründen vorher noch mal halb acht
aufgezeichnet es tut sich was an der
front und es ist nicht das was die
russische militärführung und ihr
präsident geplant hatten statt angriff
rückzug stadt offensive rückschlag die
ukrainische armee macht insbesondere in
der region um die zweitgrößte stadt
attraktiv boden gut sie hat dort nicht
nur den russischen vormarsch weitgehend
gestoppt sondern startet auch
gegenangriffe ein symbolischer erfolg
auf video ukrainische soldaten an einem
grenzposten zu russland herr präsident
wir haben sie erreicht wir sind da
melden sie nach kiew ein unabhängiges
gesamtbild der lage zu gewinnen ist
nicht einfach da beide seiten die
berichterstattung möglichkeiten
einschränken und die situation natürlich
gefährlich ist zwischen nikolajew und
person verläuft die südliche frontlinie
sollte der russischen armee hier ein
durchbruch gelingen dann wäre die
ukraine vom schwarzen meer abgeschnitten
aus dem dorf poly buske ukrainisch
kontrolliert jetzt unser reporter dara
hassanzadeh
wir fahren in richtung front der krieg
hier im südwesten in der region nikolov
wird vor allem aus der distanz geführt
artillerie gegen artillerie wir stoppen
noch außerhalb der reichweite von
russischen geschützen der presseoffizier
zeigt uns schützengräben an der front
sind sie baugleich
in solchen unterständen haaren
frontsoldaten aus unter artilleriefeuer
es super eng und kalt und über uns ist
nur ein haufen erde und beton
weiterfahrt ins dorf prix buske
die schule ist zerschossen das dorf
liegt in unmittelbarer front näher die
letzte verteidigungslinie der
ukrainischen armee ist keine fünf
kilometer entfernt dahinter liegt das
was man schlachtfeld nennt
ein frontsoldat sorgt hier für unsere
sicherheit das dorf ist seit tagen unter
russischem beschuss 3000 menschen lebten
hier
die dorfkirche sie ist sie war dem
patriarchat moskaus zugehörig nur eine
ikone zeugt noch von ihrer existenz noch
eine handvoll bewohner sind geblieben
trotz alltäglichem raketeneinschlag
haben sie angst
ja
nur verrückte haben keine angst
und ich bin kein dummkopf er ist bauer
sein hof und sein land das ist sein
leben wenn er ginge sagt er uns dann
würde er genau das verlieren sein leben
so gegen acht haben sie los gefeiert von
dort drüben nach darüber vier raketen
sind über mein dach geflogen
sie sind wirklich verrückt geworden wie
losgelassene kettenhunde
gestern wurde dieses haus getroffen die
bewohner hatten erst vor zwei tagen ihr
heim verlassen es hat ihr leben gerettet
die russische armee verfügt über
deutlich mehrere schütze und munition
hinzu kommt ein reichweiten vorteil die
russische artillerie schießt um zehn
kilometer weiter als die ukrainische
das dorf ist völlig zerbombten zentrum
völlig zerstört und in unserer straße
das haus wurde auch geschossen
nur zwölf meter von nicola und seinem
sohn entfernt ein blindgänger er schlug
vor einer woche ein und ist inzwischen
entschärft von der ukrainischen armee
und wir bleiben noch beim thema mit dir
jetzt hanna und christian wir beginnen
mit einem historischen kurswechsel nach
finnland hat nun auch schweden offiziell
entschieden dass es der nato beitreten
will dafür hat sich eine mehrheit im
schwedischen parlament ausgesprochen
laut schwedens ministerpräsidentin
anders schon ist geplant den antrag
zeitnah und gemeinsam mit finnland
einzureichen gleichzeitig warnte
russlands präsident putin die nato davor
die beiden möglichen neumitglieder
aufzurüsten dies würde eine reaktion
russlands provozieren sagte er
die eu-außenministerin und minister
haben sich darauf verständigt die
ukraine mit weiteren 500 millionen euro
für waffenkäufe zu unterstützen eine
einigung zum geplanten importstopp für
russisches öl konnten sie dagegen nicht
erreichen ungarn blockiert das
öl-embargo weiterhin und fordert
unterstützung in milliarden-höhe oder
eine längere übergangsfrist pläne für
das embargo gibt es seit fast zwei
wochen es soll nach sechs monaten in
kraft treten ungarn und die slowakei
sollen für die umsetzung 20 monate zeit
bekommen
frankreich hat eine neue
premierministerin elisabeth morgen wird
neue regierungschefin präsident makro
nannte die bisherige arbeitsministerin
heute zur nachfolgerin von jokers tags
die 61 jährige ist die zweite frau in
diesem amt sie gilt als linksgerichtet
und kann man so bei der nahende
parlamentswahl helfen neben
konservativen auch linke wähler gruppen
anzusprechen kast ex hatte zuvor seinen
rücktritt eingereicht was in frankreich
nach einer präsidentschaftswahl als
formalie gilt
den deutschen waldbesitzern ist durch
dürre und schädlingsbefall in den
vergangenen jahren einen
milliardenschaden entstanden
die bundesregierung hat jetzt bei einer
sonder agrarministerkonferenz
finanzielle unterstützt versprochen bis
ende der legislaturperiode sollen 900
millionen euro bereitgestellt werden
zudem soll das bundeswaldgesetz
angepasst werden der deutsche
forstwirtschaftsrat schätzt dass der
umbau der wälder etwa 50 milliarden euro
kosten wird seit 2008 zehn sind nach
angaben von bundesagrarminister erste
mir insgesamt 400.000 hektar fläche
entstanden umweltschützer sehen
allerdings auch eine verantwortung bei
der forstwirtschaft sie fordern unter
anderem weniger holzeinschlag
wenn es bei ihnen in diesen tagen an der
tür klingelt dann kann das natürlich der
paketbote seien wie üblich aber diesmal
eben auch einer von 100.000 interview an
die ausschwärmen im amtlichen auftrag
und sich erstens nicht abwimmeln lassen
und zweitens mehr haben als man schnell
eine kurze frage der zensus
2022 startet drei monate lang sollen
mehr als zehn millionen menschen an der
haustür befragt werden nachdem man ihnen
das vorher angekündigt hat die teilnahme
ist verpflichtend sagt das statistische
bundesamt und wohl schon mal
prophylaktisch dazu man solle bitte
freundlich sein zu den
erhebungsbeauftragten
was das ganze bringen soll und wo es
noch fragen gibt an die befrager dazu
jetzt patricia schäfer
wer wohnt unter diesen dächern wie viele
menschen in einer wohnung und wie ist
ihr familienstand es ist ein blick
hinter die fassade des sensors 2022 in
dem ab heute menschen befragt werden im
namen des staates überall in deutschland
nach name alter und mitbewohnern zum
beispiel im moment mal steht dass nicht
alles in den melderegistern
man weiß eben dass sich über die jahre
bestimmte ungenauigkeiten einschleichen
in den melderegistern daten auch dadurch
dass sich menschen eben nicht abmelden
wenn sie ins ausland verziehen oder eben
wenn sie einfach nicht korrekt gemeldet
sind rund zehn millionen zufällig
ausgewählte haushalte bekommen deshalb
besuch von helfern mit dem hübschen
namen
erhebungsbeauftragte erkennungszeichen
die blaue umhängetasche und ein ausweis
hallo größe sind mein name ist wird von
der erhebungsstelle wer angeschrieben
wurde muss auskunft geben auf fragen wie
sechs interviews hat stefan luther hat
heute geführt und seinen fragenkatalog
wurde bisher bereitwillig beantwortet ob
berufstätig ist ob jemand rentner ist
bei kindern ob sie zur schule gehen das
ist alles was gefragt wird das sind
keine keine großen tiefgreifenden fragen
da sind wirklich allgemeine auskünfte
erteilt werden müssen so reibungslos wie
heute lief es nicht immer
1987 wollte die mehrheit der deutschen
sich nicht teilen lassen es gab heftige
proteste gegen die volkszählung
warnungen vor einem überwachungsstaat
tatsächlich wurde damals die anonymität
nicht immer gewahrt es gab zum beispiel
bußgelder für zu unrecht gezahlte
sozialleistungen weil die daten aus der
volkszählung an ämter weitergeleitet
wurden heute wird der datenschutz groß
geschrieben und klagen gegen den zensus
laufen ins leere
das verfahren ist verfassungsrechtlich
überprüft und offenbar wasserdicht das
gesetz sieht anders als damals vor dass
man ein so genanntes rückspiel verbot
hat also das was die zensus leute
erheben das dürfen sie nicht an die
fachbehörden zurückgeben aber nicht nur
personen daten werden neu erhoben auch
bei wohnungen und gebäuden wird
nachgezählt das heißt für alle die
wohnraum besitzen einen fragebogen
ausfüllen damit der zensus 2022 erstmals
liefern kann die mieten pro quadratmeter
er liefert den leerstand und er liefert
den energetischen voraussetzungen in der
wohnung oder in den gebäuden ich glaube
wir alle erkennen welche energie krise
vielleicht auf uns zukommt und da sind
bessere
grund datengrundlagen glaube ich für die
planung und entscheidung der
entscheidungsträger unerlässlich
realistische daten stadtplanung ins
leere das soll der zensus 2022 liefern
aber das dauert noch die ergebnisse
werden erst ende nächsten jahres
veröffentlicht
die erhebungsbeauftragten bei der
erschöpfung solche wortungetüme ist
dieses land ganz weit vorn im
heute-journal update nachher fragen dazu
an den bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten
jetzt der blick auf ein land das kaum
einen blick von außen zulässt was
passiert wenn das corona virus auf
menschen trifft die eines der
schlechtesten gesundheitssysteme der
welt haben und für die es keine chance
gibt zu erfahren was da gerade wirklich
passiert weil ihr gnadenloser diktator
die grenzen ab regelt und gleichzeitig
hilfe aus dem ausland ablehnt wenn
dieser diktator seinen beamten jetzt
öffentlich vorwirft sie hätten zitat die
krise nicht richtig erkannt dann können
wir ahnen wie ernst die lage sein muss
in nordkorea ulf röller
nordkoreas diktator kim jong un ist als
krisenmanager unterwegs besucht eine
apotheke die die staatliche propaganda
wohl extra für seinen auftritt
hergerichtet hat und selbst das reicht
dem großen führer nicht die apotheken
seien unzureichend für den virus
ausbruch ausgestattet kritisierte er die
straßen der hauptstadt pjöngjang sind
menschenleer die vielen desinfektions
teams können nicht darüber
hinwegtäuschen dass nordkorea schlecht
auf den ausbruch vorbereitet ist
impfstoffe aus dem ausland hat das
abgeschottete land abgelehnt die
ratschläge im staatlichen fernsehen
wirken fast hilflos
schlafen sie genug trinken sie genug
essen sie leicht verdauliches und spülen
sie den mund mit salzwasser aus
das virus trifft auf ein bitterarmes und
ungeimpften land den meisten geht es bei
weitem nicht so gut wie der
vorzeigefamilie mit ihrem vorzeige
optimismus
ich bin zuversichtlich dass wir mit der
richtigen medizin das virus besiegen
können der virus ausbruch ist eine
katastrophe für das land der diktator
kim jong un hat sich entschieden dies
der welt zu offenbaren es könnte ein
hilferuf seien für medikamente und
impfstoffe
bisher allerdings hat nordkorea jegliche
hilfe gelegt kim jong-un muss sich
entscheiden ohne hilfe vom ausland
versinkt sein land wohl im corona chaos
und jetzt meldungen aus der wirtschaft
die mal nicht von umsatzzielen handeln
und dem erschließen neuer märkte
sondern vom gegenteil hanna allerdings
es geht um russland und um mcdonald's
die fast-food-kette zieht sich jetzt
komplett aus dem land zurück und ist
damit nicht allein auch renault kehrt
russland nun den rücken genauso wie
viele andere firmen und sina mainitz in
frankfurt das wird teuer für die
unternehmen warum gehen sie dann auch
diesen schritt da sind tatsächlich
milliarden us-dollar die mcdonald's da
abschreiben kann nach über 30 jahren
zieht sich die fast food kette aus
russland zurück und sucht nun einen
russischen käufer für ihre dortigen 850
filialen
seit anfang märz sind die mcdonald's
standorte in russland als reaktion auf
den russischen angriff auf die ukraine
geschlossen etwa 62.000 angestellte
sollen bis zum endgültigen verkauf
weiter bezahlt werden der rückzug von
mcdonald's aus russland ist sowohl
symbolisch als auch wirtschaftlich von
größter bedeutung
mcdonald's war nämlich eines der ersten
westlichen unternehmen das sich 1990
nach ende des kalten krieges in russland
niedergelassen hat heute hat nun auch
der autokonzern renault angekündigt sich
komplett aus dem russlandgeschäft zu
verabschieden und geht damit einen
schritt ihn schon viele andere große
konzerne vorher gegangen sind so haben
sich seit kriegsbeginn auch sap shell
oder siemens vollständig und langfristig
aus ihrem geschäft mit russland
zurückgezogen wie bei so vielen dingen
im leben gibt es auch hier nicht nur den
einen grund lieferbedingungen unter
strengen auflagen der internationalen
sanktionen machen es firmen zunehmend
schwierig ihre geschäfte mit russland
aufrecht zu erhalten hinzu kommt
politischer und gesellschaftlicher druck
wenn man mit russland verhandelt für
unternehmen und investoren wird es immer
wichtiger bei geschäften auf ethisch
moralisch vertretbare kriterien und auf
nachhaltigkeit zu achten danke für diese
einordnung gerne
die tarifverhandlungen für die
beschäftigten im sozial- und
erziehungsberufen sind heute in die wohl
entscheidende dritte runde gestartet
verdi und der beamtenbund dbb wollen bis
mittwoch eine lösung im tarifkonflikt
mit den kommunalen arbeitgebern finden
im kern geht es um bessere
arbeitsbedingungen und höhere löhne für
etwa 330.000 beschäftigten
februar und märz waren die verhandlungen
ohne ergebnis geblieben
wegen heftiger gewitter und unwetter war
die feuerwehr am nachmittag im westen
deutschlands vielerorts im dauereinsatz
erneut betroffen war auch das ahrtal in
rheinland pfalz das im vergangenen
sommer von einer struth schwer zerstört
wurde so liefen in bad
neuenahr-ahrweiler zahlreiche keller
voll straßen wurden überflutet und es
kann zu unfällen in köln fielen in
kürzester zeit stellenweise bis zu 25
liter regen pro quadratmeter
ein ganz besonderes spektakel
gab es heute am frühen morgen mit etwas
glück am himmel zu bestaunen eine totale
mondfinsternis
kurz vor der morgendämmerung schob sich
der vollmond für einige minuten in den
schatten der erde mancherorts färbte er
sich dabei deutlich zu blutmond wie etwa
hier in spanien deutschland war die
mondfinsternis zum leidwesen vieler
frühaufsteher leider kaum sichtbar da
der himmel bereits recht helfer
ja aber zum glück gibt's ja fernsehen
das waren wirklich tolle bilder und das
war unsere welt an diesem montag und die
nächsten nachrichten gibt's hier gegen
23 55 in unserem heute journal update
mit nazan captain einen sehr angenehmen
abend schießen
[Musik]
guten abend das geht wirklich früh los
in diesem jahr mit den heftigen gewitter
schule in der vergangenen nacht zogen
die ersten gewitter heran breiteten sich
dann richtung norden und osten aus am
nachmittag gewitterte es in baden
württemberg aber auch im saarland in
rheinland pfalz nordrhein westfalen und
am abend gab es dann gewitter im
westlichen niedersachsen dort ist es
jetzt vor allen dingen noch regen und
auch südlich von münchen lebt es zurzeit
stark das kräftigste aber was für ein
gewitter noch zu vermelden haben findet
hier statt zwischen thüringen und
sachsen das ist ja eine gewitterzelle
die von erfurt weiter richtung leipzig
gezogen ist und nun kurs auf dresden
nimmt dabei wird sie aber im laufe der
nacht immer weiter in sich
zusammenfallen und sonst sollten sie
doch eigentlich eher eine ruhige nacht
erleben bei tiefsttemperaturen von 15
bis 9 grad und morgen steigen die
temperaturen im westen und im süden dann
auf 23 bis 28 grad im nordosten bleibt
es bei 19 bis 23 grad etwas kühler am
künstlern der ostsee 16 bis 18 grad und
auch morgen kann es noch einige schauer
und gewitter am vormittag geben wohl
keine unwetter mehr wie heute die werden
im laufe des nachmittags weiter nach
südosten ziehen dann kann sich an der
ostsee auch mal wieder die sonne zeigen
am freundlichsten aber wird es im
südwesten der mittwoch bringt uns dann
viel sonnenschein aber schon am
donnerstag kommen neue gewitter von
westen heran bei temperaturen bis 32
grad und die gewitter begleitet uns dann
auch noch am freitag bei schwülheißen
werten bis 33 grad im südwesten guten
abend